hey what is up guys mkbhd here and they
said this year 2014 would be the year of
the wearable 2014 is set to be the year
of wearable tech electronics that are
physically attached to your body so was
it
at the beginning of 2014 about 10 months
ago we looked at the five best wearables
that you can buy and these are all first
generation products so they're the
beginning of a new product category and
they could all sort of tell you if you
have a new notification they could tell
you if something new was happening but
if you actually wanted to do anything
about it or if you wanted to take action
or if you wanted to reply to something
like a new message then you still have
to take your phone out your pocket
anyway so that's i guess the main
difference between what we had then and
what we have now at google i o this
summer we saw the introduction of
android wear so it's google's version of
their android operating system for
wearable tech or smart watches
specifically it's not sexy or anything
but it's very smart and it's actually
gotten a couple of software updates
since it first rolled out and has a
bunch of new features now and it's a lot
better looking and wearable tech has
made a lot of steps forward since that
introduction so now here we are at the
end of 2014 with a very different very
new list these are your new top five
best wearables that you can buy right
now number five is the samsung gear s so
this is a tizen smartwatch and we've
talked a lot about tizen in the past and
what it means to android but essentially
the gear s is this huge curved amoled
display on a smartwatch it's not small
at all it's not subtle at all it's this
really big thing but it's one of the
more innovative designs and one of the
more interesting looking things we've
seen this year in the smartwatch game
and it actually turns out to be a really
good product mostly because it's one of
the few that actually doesn't require
being tethered to or attached to a
smartphone to work it has its own
independent functions it has its own
independent actions it can do it has a
freaking web browser built in so if you
want to load up a web page it'll start
chugging that snapdragon 400 and half a
gig of ram and it'll load up a web page
so if you need to do some things on the
go
this is actually a pretty solid option
and like i said it's not small it's not
subtle
but it's pretty interesting looking
samsung by the way has loaded the market
with a bunch of other smartwatch options
and they're basically saturating the
market in typical samsung fashion uh one
of the other noteworthy ones is the
samsung gear live which is their android
wear version of a smartwatch pretty
traditional looking smartwatch as far as
they are concerned and they have the
gear too as well which is a sort of a
follow up to their tizen based galaxy
gear number four is the pebble and this
is actually one of the returners from
the video that happened at the beginning
this year 10 months ago which means it's
still really good at what it does
because it's very focused on just
delivering your notifications and it's
still really good at that
now it's also not going to let you take
action really on these notifications the
way the android wear smart watches do so
if you get a new message you can mark it
as red or ignore it but that's about it
you still have to take your phone out
your pocket to reply but it still has a
display that allows it to have a
seven-day battery life it's not the most
premium feeling in the world but they
also now have a version called the
pebble steel that's a bit more expensive
but i would recommend it because it's
much more premium feeling has the metal
band has the clasp that feels much more
like a normal timepiece than the rubber
and plastic of the original pebble so
the pebble and the pebble steel are
still very easy to recommend for the
simple delivery of notifications number
three is the asus zen watch now there's
nothing wrong with the square display on
your wrist it does look a little bit
unconventional it doesn't look quite as
much like a normal watch but i think the
one that strikes the balance best is the
zen watch it's probably easily the best
looking smart watch that has a full
square resolution display it has that
brushed aluminum around the sides it has
that subtle curve around the edges it
has the leather band it has that clasp
like a normal timepiece so it's very
nice at striking the balance between
something that looks like a timepiece
but also gives you that sort of a
high-tech look in the full square
display
i i wouldn't necessarily pick it over
the number one and number two but i do
want to put it high on this list because
it's worth recommending it's a great
performer it has a solid battery life
it's got nice specs it's pretty solid
and i wouldn't have any trouble
recommending it to someone who's looking
to get into a smart watch right now
number two is the lg g watch r and this
is an android wear smart watch similar
to ones we've talked about before but it
looks a lot more like a normal time
piece because it has a round display and
actually has the notches around the
display and the numbers as well
it has a leather-ish band that's not
really that premium feeling and there is
no metal version but it still looks a
lot closer to a normal watch than the
sort of a mini computer that the square
ones look like on your wrist there also
is a square version of this it's called
the lg g watch no r and it was
introduced at google i o and that was
one of the first that lg introduced but
the g watch r for round is much better
looking i think and is easily something
i could recommend but the number one i
think is the one that you guys probably
all saw coming number one is the moto
360. the moto 360 is a round smart watch
and it's also running android wear and
it has a metal version too so if you
prefer that premium look and feel closer
to a normal watch it has a clasp it has
everything like that you have that
option i think it's one of the best
looking smart watches actually might be
the best looking smart watch period with
the minimal distractions around the
display and the almost zero bezel has
that chamfer edge around the display it
has that tiny little bar at the bottom
that people like to complain about at
first but you'll find that it just sort
of melts away and disappears from your
revision when you're checking stuff
after about a day or two so it's a
beautiful option for a smart watch this
is the one on the list that i did do a
full review on so if you're looking to
get into smart watches in general or you
just want to know more about what the
best of a smart watch right now can
offer check out that link right below
the like button it'll have the moto 360
review and i'll also link my android
wear review to go over all the functions
of what a smart watch can do so honestly
if you're trying to buy a smart watch
especially since it's the holiday season
now it's basically a toss-up between
like the top three or four depending on
what sort of a design you like and what
functionality you want the clasp design
the material design also there's a sony
option the sony smartwatch 3 and there's
also those samsung options that i talked
about as they start to flood the market
uh so really there are a lot more
options than you had at the beginning of
the year also the apple watch not the
iwatch the apple watch was announced uh
this year but it doesn't sell until next
year and there are still a whole bunch
of questions that we have about it i'll
leave the video that i did about that
also below uh it's a question mark for
me in terms of functionality and what
it's actually going to be able to do and
what the interface will look like and
all these other things but best watch
that video it's totally separate and
it's an interesting concept but we all
know that once apple tends to get into
things that's what really gets the
competition going and that makes better
products for us there's also a new
version of google glass expected with
internals from intel instead of ti to be
released next year and we keep hearing
about these murmurings of bringing
google glass back it was actually on the
top five list at the beginning of this
year for best wearables but it dropped
off and it's been pretty quiet lately
but we also always had in the back of
our mind that thought of a consumer
version of google glass for a lower
price tag that we just straight up never
saw i mean google glass is still 1500
bucks right now so i wouldn't be
surprised if that was resurrected
re-brought back from the dead in 2015.
so we'll see how this list evolves
during the course of 2015 and what new
stuff comes out keep an eye out for ces
stuff keep an eye out for new google
glass stuff and also let me know in the
comment section below what you're
looking forward to in the whole wearable
game maybe you're not interested in
smart watches at all maybe you want
stuff to be more on your face or maybe
you want a moto 360 without the black
bar whatever it is let me know what
you're thinking in the comments section
thanks for watching and i'll talk to you
guys in the next one peace
you